where is the soul stone
you should know it extracts
a terrible price how is it you know this
place so well
a lifetime ago i too saw the stones i
even healed one in my hand
but it cast me out banished me here
guiding others to a treasure i cannot
possess
[Music]
what you seek lies in front of you
as does what you fear
what's this the price
saul holds a special place among the
infinity stones
you might say it has a certain
wisdom tell me what it needs
to ensure that whoever possesses it
understands its power
the stone demands a sacrifice
of what in order to take the stone
you must lose that which you love
a soul for a soul
hey everybody it's charlie you probably
heard about the huge red skull news last
night the russos were doing a live
commentary
someone asked them about red skull in
this soul stone
scene they revealed that because thanos
took the stone successfully
he was freed in the process and is now
free to leave vormir implying that he's
alive again like he's returned to the
world of the living
and free to pursue an infinity stone as
he pleases
like he's going to continue seeking the
infinity stones
i did not expect him to return after
this movie so we gotta break this down
this means a couple big things but if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the marvel videos
there's a new round of that infinity war
giveaway that i'll explain at the end of
the video too
so the big thing here is that we can
kind of confirm what happened
when thanos sacrificed gamora so it
explains some of the mechanics the soul
stone
in the mcu it's a little bit different
from the soul stone in the comics but
they've confirmed that this soul stone's
power
is controlling life and death so thanos
sacrifices that which he loves gamora
gets the soul stone but in the process
he trades a soul for a soul
like the red skull says so you have to
imagine that when thanos gets ported
down here and he finds it in his hand
there's a deleted moment up on this hill
here where red skull
is cackling in delight because you have
to remember that he's a genius he has
all the same powers as captain america
so of course he'd probably be spending
all the years that he was trapped there
finding a way to get out
meaning he needed someone to release him
by sacrificing someone else
so the roosters are saying that red
skull is coming back there are three
easy ways that i think you can do that
including a really big
but really short oh crap moment during
avengers 4
but also this whole big red skull twist
also is a good way of explaining
how they can bring gamora back because
we know she's coming back for guardians
meaning that in avengers 4 regardless of
alternate universes
second infinity gauntlet however the
avengers fix the universe
you still need to get this gamora out of
this soul stone
in order to do that you have to trade a
soul for
a soul the easiest way to do that and
deal
with thanos is to trade thanos for
gamora but
the problem with that is that either
thanos would have to sacrifice himself
or someone would have to love thanos so
that they could sacrifice him because
that's part of the rules you have to
sacrifice that which you love and nebula
would be a good candidate for that but
it doesn't seem like she loves thanos so
i don't know how that would work
so it's still speculation about how they
deal with thanos ultimately because
they'll defeat him that's the whole idea
avengers 4 is going to have a more
hopeful ending where they fix the
universe
and the marvel movies are going to
effectively put thanos on a shelf
somewhere for a long long time like they
spent the last 10 years setting him up
it's not like he's going to continue to
be a super big character if they bring
him back after avengers 4 it would be as
like a funny you know really quick
moment during secret wars where you have
all these different realities blending
together
like oh here's a universe where thanos
was doing something else and survived
the end of avengers 4
so even if it isn't going to be thanos
at the end of avengers 4
somebody has to sacrifice themselves or
sacrifice something else
to get gamora back hopefully it doesn't
have to be captain america
because the person that you sacrifice to
get gamora back doesn't necessarily have
to have any pre-existing relationship
with her
like thanos didn't know anything about
red skull before this gamora didn't know
him
it just means trading a soul for a soul
but
the easy ways you bring red skull back
like russo say he's free to leave vormir
free to pursue an infinity stone
that implies that they intend on paying
that off like he actually will go
seek some of the infinity stones after
this but because of the way the actors
and the producers have been talking
about the level
of craziness ramping up in avengers 4 it
seemingly confirms
multiverse we learned about quantum
energy ant-man and the wasp post-credits
scene
all the promise of all that crazy
unpredictable time travel
the easiest and most rewarding way i
think to bring the red skull back
is if there's a moment during avengers 4
just a really quick scene
where they're cycling through other
realities just trying to see
and get clues about how to fix things in
their own reality
and they find a darkest timeline where
red skull
really did assemble all six of the
infinity stones
just a really quick moment where captain
america is like hell
no and they just cycle to the next
reality because you have to imagine the
run time is going to be about the same
as infinity war so it's not like they're
going to travel between
hundreds and hundreds of different
realities second easiest way if they
don't want to do darkest timeline
infinity gauntlet red skull is that you
finally have our captain america
kill him at some point to end his ark
and be like this is the end of the red
skull
or three if they want to leave him for
another space based movie you could have
him become
a minor villain or an anti-hero during a
captain marvel sequel
or nova or one of the other future
space-based movies in phase four phase
five
but i think the idea is that he's done
as a main character so there's not going
to be any huge
red skull movie down the line if or when
he shows up again
it's going to be like a holy crap moment
like this soul stone scene but that's
probably about
it if you remember there was actually a
plot in the comics where the avengers
fired ultron into deep space as a way to
deal with them he ended up surviving and
taking over a mechanical race
called the phalanx and turning them into
his own private space army to attack the
cree with he became a plot point during
annihilation conquest so it was like him
showing up
many comic book arcs later like surprise
[ __ ] you thought i was dead but i'm
alive
they've kind of done that with this soul
stone scene already so like i said when
i think
red skull comes back he's a relatively
minor plot point but rewarding for the
fans like if you've been paying
attention this whole time it'll be a
really cool
easter egg next big question i know
you're asking if he leaves vormir
how does he leave because he's there by
himself i think the idea is is that he's
been here for many many years
guiding people to the soul stone
unsuccessfully like people have tried
and failed to get the soul stone
they would have brought their own
spacecraft so the planet is probably
littered with spacecraft or the bones of
spacecraft of the people who tried to
get the soul stone so it's not like
there isn't anything on the planet it's
just obviously they left that for future
movies to deal with
so let me know in the comments red skull
comes back in a future movie
how do you want them to bring him back
there's a new round of the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video
there'll be a whole bunch more stuff
like this red skull reveal on that
commentary track so in a couple weeks
when that drops i'll do some new videos
about that too but leave all your
requests in the comments below
some of you been requesting a cloak and
dagger video so i will do cloak and
dagger finale in season 2 later tonight
while you wait for everything click here
for all those other infinity war deleted
scenes
and click here to re-watch that venom
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome i'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]